-Welcome, welcome, welcome,
welcome to "The Tonight Show,"
ladies and gentlemen.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We're here.
We got a full crowd.
Thank you for watching.
Well, guys,
this is very exciting.
After nearly six years,
Adele has finally released
a new song, "Easy On Me."
[ Cheers and applause ]
As soon as it came out,
all you heard around the world
was wine bottles uncorking.
[ Bottles uncorking ]
[ Laughter ]
Yep. Right --
[ Uncorking continues ]
[ Uncorking stops ]
Oh.
Right now everyone is pulling up
next to each other at red lights
with tears in their eyes like --
[sniffles]
"Adele, yeah. I'm --
It's -- It's fantastic."
In the music video, Adele is
driving a car in black and white
singing about the past,
while an Uber passenger
in the back seat is like,
"Uh, you can
just let me out here.
Uh, I'm good."
[ Laughter ]
"You want to hear my new band?"
"Not really. We're..."
Okay, sure.
Some more entertainment news --
the new "Halloween" movie,
"Halloween Kills," is out today.
Yeah, you can tell times
have changed
'cause now we're all rooting
for the guy wearing a mask.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Like, "Don't take it off."
-Come on.
-Of course, Michael Myers
is a little older.
In one big fight scene,
Jamie Lee Curtis hurts Michael
by hiding
his blood-pressure medication.
[ Laughter ]
It's a -- It's a scary scene.
-He's old.
He's a very old person.
-It's a scary scene. Oh! Yeah.
He's like, "Ohh, I was supposed
to take one at 7:30."
[ Laughter ]
-"Where's my AARP card?"
-Michael is so old,
the film ends with him
playing quarterback
for the Tampa Bay Buccaneers.
[ Audience ohs ]
[ Laughter ]
-Hey. Hey.
-No, no, no, that's right.
-Hey!
-No, Michael is so old,
at the end,
Jeff Bezos shows up
and launches him into space.
[ Laughter ]
That's some good jokes there.
-Come on, man.
What else? What else?
Speaking of Halloween,
I saw that a list came out
for the most popular costumes
for adults this year.
They also put a list
of least popular costumes.
Just check this out --
found it interesting.
-This year's top costumes
for adults include witch,
vampire, ghost, cat, and pirate.
And at the bottom of the list,
we have sexy McRib,
sexy Mitch McConnell's chin,
and sexy chess piece
because you thought
"Queen's Gambit"
would be the Netflix show
everyone's talking about.
-Ohh.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Rats.
[ Laughs ]
No, not anymore.
Some political news --
after President Biden's approval
rating dropped as low as 37%,
a new CNN poll
has his numbers back up to 50%.
Yeah, so Biden looked like
he was in his 30s,
but is actually in the 50s.
In the polling world, that's
also known as a Paul Rudd.
[ Laughter ]
Yep.
[ Laughter continues ]
Approval ratings are like
iPhone batteries --
at 50%, you're okay --
around 30%
is when you start to panic.
[ Laughter ]
Get this --
a new report says that
after months without working
during the pandemic,
a lot of airline pilots
are rusty.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, you can sort of tell.
Listen to this captain's
announcement that we found.
Listen.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, it's -- Oh, no, that's...
-Oh.
[ Applause ]
-Come on, that's...
[ Applause continues ]
[ Chuckles ]
"The tip." Yeah, no.
[ Light laughter ]
Speaking of air travel,
Virgin Galactic plans to offer
commercial flights to space,
but the start date
was just delayed
because they have to
refurbish the spacecrafts.
A refurbished spacecraft?
[ Light laughter ]
I don't even like it
when Spectrum gives me
a refurbished cable box.
[ Laughter ]
Branson is like,
"Just a few refurbishes.
The color, the seats,
the rocket, the wings."
[ Laughter ]
After last night's game between
the Buccaneers and the Eagles,
I saw that two players
did a jersey swap.
But one of them was having
a little trouble.
Watch this.
This is real.
-So far these past
couple of games.
-Well, the difference -- not
just for me, but as a unit...
-Yeah.
-Just trying to get
our run game together,
you know --
you know, after practices,
coming together for an hour
and finding what runs --
what runs we like as a whole.
[ Laughter ]
And like I'll tell --
I'll tell everybody...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Yeah, towards the end,
he was just like...
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Applause continues ]
[ Grunting ]
"Forget it.
I'll just live like this.
Alright. Oh."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, that's what it looks like
when I'm convinced
I can change my pants
without taking off my shoes.
[ Laughter ]
"Crap."
Meanwhile,
Tom Brady snapped his fingers,
and his jersey flew onto
a hanger like Mary Poppins.
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
this is very interesting ---
I saw that Twitter
will start testing ads
in the reply section of tweets.
And some people --
Tariq, what are you doing?
-♪ Go easy on me, baby ♪
[ Applause ]
♪ I was still a child ♪
♪ Didn't get the chance
to feel ♪
-Tariq, Tariq, Tariq, Tariq!
Hey, man!
Yo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh.
-What are you doing, dude?
-I'm listening
to Adele's new song, man.
-Oh, yeah, yeah.
I could tell.
-Yeah. Sorry. I know you got to
tell your jokes and everything,
but just go ahead.
Do -- Do your --
Do your thing, man.
-Thank you.
[ Light laughter ]
As I was saying, Twitter
is gonna start testing ads,
but a lot of people --
-♪ Go easy... ♪
-Higgins.
-♪ ...on me, baby ♪
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪ I was still a child ♪
-Higgins! Hey, Higgins!
Hey, Higgins!
Cut it out! Higgins!
-What? What?
-Cut it out, dude.
-I'm listening to
Adele's new song.
-I know you're listening
to Adele's new song.
I know -- we all love Adele,
but can we please
keep it together?
We have Oscar Isaac
on the show tonight,
and I don't want
to embarrass myself.
[ Cheers and applause ]
'Cause he's --
-♪ Go easy... ♪
-Wait, Oscar. No, Oscar!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ ...on me, baby ♪
-♪ I was still a child ♪
♪ I didn't get the chance ♪
♪ To feel the world around me ♪
♪ I had no time to choose
what I chose to do ♪
♪ So go easy on me ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Let's get to the show.
Happy Friday!
Give it up for The Roots!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ White doves at my doorstep ♪
♪ Unh ♪
♪ Those are... ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪♪
♪ 21 pounds ♪
♪ Ooh ♪
♪♪
-Yes!
Oh, wow!
What a show
we have for you tonight!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Our first guest
is a very, very busy man.
You can see him
in the new movie "Dune,"
which is out October 21st.
[ Audience cheers ]
I know.
He's also in "The Card Counter,"
which is on demand now.
He's in "Addams Family 2."
-Whoo!
[ Audience cheers ]
And he stars in the HBO series
"Scenes from a Marriage"
with Jessica Chastain.
Oscar Isaac is here.
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on!
-The one, the only.
-Come on!
[ Cheers and applause continue ]
-Plus, her new comedy special
"Good Timing with Jo Firestone"
is streaming right now
on Peacock.
This thing is so funny,
and it's fantastic.
The idea is she teaches
senior citizens
how to do stand-up comedy.
[ Light laughter ]
And then, at the end,
they do a live show.
-Oh.
-And it is --
-It is great.
-It's heartwarming,
but it is so funny.
And she is just --
she is brilliant.
Jo Firestone is with me.
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on! Jo!
-And we have great music
from Alec Benjamin.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Ah! We like Alec Benjamin.
"Older."
Then later in the show,
all-new "Thank You Notes."
But I want to do a quick
little mention here right now.
There's is a new book
that I picked up.
-Oh!
-Yeah.
This will make a good gift
right here.
This is "Music Is History"
by Questlove.
-Whoo!
-This is out Tuesday,
October...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...Tuesday, October 19th,
this book comes out,
so pre-order it right now.
But it's -- you were telling me
about this.
I didn't believe that you would
actually get this done
because you just directed
an award-winning documentary,
but you did this.
-Yeah.
-It -- Basically,
it goes every year
from 1971 to present of, like,
the biggest songs
of the year or music.
-Or my favorite songs
of that year, yeah.
-Yeah, and also the times,
and how it reflects the times.
-Yeah.
It's a book of playlists.
-Yeah, it's a book of playlists
and great stories and --
around the songs
and stuff I did not even know,
like, certain cool things about
the police I didn't understand.
What year --
I'm going to guess --
What is the biggest year that
you've discussed in this book?
Ready?
Can I write it down?
-Sure.
[ Light laughter ]
-I don't have any paper,
but...
-Use a napkin.
[ Laughter ]
-I have a tissue.
♪♪
Thanks, dude.
[ Sneeze ]
-Oh!
Oh!
♪♪
-Mm-hmm.
I don't want it to bleed
through the napkin.
♪♪
-37 B.C.?
[ Light laughter ]
-Alright.
Alright, Questlove,
in this book
of your music history,
what do you have the --
Oh, I did bleed
through the desk.
[ Laughter ]
It's a Sharpie.
This is an expensive desk.
Alright.
Alright, Questlove,
in this book of music,
"Music Is History"...
-Mm-hmm.
-...what is the biggest year
chapter in the book?
And then I will reveal it.
Ready? Tell me.
-I would probably say '83,
the year of "Thriller."
-Oh!
[ Audience ohs ]
-[ Imitates buzzer ]
Overbid.
-So close.
-♪ Wah-wah-wah-wah ♪
-Close. That was so close.
-[ Laughs ] Wait. Yeah.
But --
Yeah, it was '83 "Thriller."
I thought "Thriller," Prince.
Yeah, I guess it...
-I mean, '84 was --
but, you know,
I talked about
why "Thriller" was big.
-Yeah, exactly.
-Yeah.
-Not when the hits
started coming out.
-Yeah, not before he was a
megastar, but the buildup to it.
-Well, I was very close.
-Yeah, you got it.
-But I'm psyched
about this, bud.
This comes out
Tuesday, October 19th.
And this is just awesome, man.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Congrats, man.
Love it.
The dude's unbelievable.
Well, guys,
it's Week 6 of the NFL season,
and this Sunday night's game
features the Seattle Seahawks
facing off
against the -- you know what?
Maybe, um...
Purell would take off the...
-I bet it would, yeah --
or hairspray.
-Oh, my God.
You just messed up, man.
-What do you mean?
-Come back and check -- check
on the desk tomorrow morning.
[ Laughter ]
-Really?
Did I mess it up?
-You got it off there, right?
♪♪
[ Light laughter ]
-I just don't want --
I know it --
Well, just I don't want --
I don't want Peacock suing me
or whatever.
-Mm.
[ Light laughter ]
-Yeah, I kind of got it off.
It kind of worked.
-Yeah.
♪♪
I think it's taking off varnish.
-Yeah.
-Oh, is that right?
-No. It's good.
-[ Chuckles ]
-It's not -- It's great.
It looks great.
♪♪
Buff it and -- Oh, 1984.
-If I said -- If I said "1983,"
wouldn't that be cool?
-Yeah,
that would have been cool.
-That's kind of funny.
Like, let me do that...
-I think Quest was talking
about when they were created,
and you were talking about
when people heard 'em.
Oh, there you go.
-What? Who got hurt?
[ Light laughter ]
-The desk.
-No, when people
heard the music.
Quest was talking about
when the music was made.
-Oh, yeah, that's my book
I'm putting out
is when people
actually heard the music.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
It's called
"I Heard the Music," right?
Listening to the radio
in my bedroom.
-Yeah, it's like -- Yeah.
"I Wa--"
"I Wasn't Ahead of my Time"
by Jimmy Fallon.
-Yeah, right.
[ Light laughter ]
-I live life
just like everyone else.
-I was of my time.
-Let me see if I can get
all this out.
-Oh.
-This should be the entire show.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
♪♪
-What I can't figure out --
-Wait, wait, whoa.
Hold on a second, Higgins.
-Oh. What? What? What was that?
You wiped something off the --
off the desk.
What did the desk say?
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
"1983"? That's...
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Bell dinging ]
-Ha! Oh, my God.
[ Cheers and applause continue ]
-Thank you, everybody.
Thank you.
We had it planned out
the whole time.
-The desk knew.
-We never -- I --
We've never met before the show.
Am I correct?
-Hey, man. You're right.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, guys, it is Week 6
of the NFL season...
[ Laughter ]
...and this Sunday night's game
features the Seattle Seahawks
facing off
against the Pittsburgh Steelers.
-Ooh.
-Now, as you know,
at the end of every season,
they give out awards
like Most Valuable Player,
but they also give out awards
during the season.
I'll show you what I mean.
It's time for
"'Tonight Show' Superlatives."
Here we go.
-♪ "Tonight Show" Superlatives ♪
♪♪
-The first player
is from the Seahawks.
This is Colby Parkinson.
He was voted...
[ Applause ]
"Costa's the bomb, dude."
This next one from the Steelers
is B.J. Finney.
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Next up from the Seahawks
is Dakoda Shepley.
He was voted...
-Really?
Wow, that's an award?
-Yeah, it's a rare award.
They rarely give it out.
Next up from the Steelers
is Derrek Tuszka.
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Next up from the Seahawks
is Jamarco Jones.
He was voted...
"You gotta be kidding.
Gotta be joking."
Next up from the Seahawks
is Cody Barton.
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Teeths?
-Teeths.
Next up from the Seahawks
is Will Dissly.
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Next up from the Seahawks
is Jake Curhan.
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
And finally, from the Seahawks
is D.K. Metcalf.
He was voted...
There you have it, everybody.
Those are your superlatives.